alright Part C at what time t where t
where zero is less than equal to t is
less than or equal to 8 is the amount of
water in the pipe at a minimum justify
your answer all right well let's define
a function W that represents the amount
of water in the pipe at any time T and
then we could figure out how to figure
out the minimum value for W over that
interval so let's just say W of T so
that's the amount of water and the pipe
at any given time T it's going to be
equal to well we start with 30 cubic
feet of water in the pipe at T equals 0
they tell us that right up here so we
start with that much and then we are
going to add or take away some amount so
then it's going to be plus we're going
to sum up from time 0 to time T remember
this is a function of T well let's sum
up our net our net inflow times times
little small changes in time and we'll
sum up all those small changes in time
from 0 to T and that'll give us our
aggregate in flowed our aggregate net
inflow so what is our net inflow well
you have the function R which says the
rate at which the water is entering and
your function D which is the rate at
which water is exiting and instead of
using T as our variables here I'm going
to use X since T is already one of our
variable our R is one of our boundaries
of integration and we can use any
variable we want it's really just a bit
of a placeholder variable for the
integration so our net inflow is R I'll
say R of X minus D of X and then DX once
again this is our net rate of inflow
this is our inflow minus R outflow so
our net rate of inflow times small
changes you could view this as time
although it's X and then we sum up from
0 to time is equal to T so this is how
much water we are going to have in the
pipe at any time at any time T so let's
so let's now think about at what point
does w hit a minimum in this interval
and there's three possibilities where W
could hit an in hit a minimum point it
couldn't hit a minimum at right at the
beginning at each at the at W of zero
at the end of our interval @w of eight
at t equals eight or it could be
someplace in between where w is at a
local maximum point in which case the
derivative of W will be equal to zero so
let's first evaluate W at the endpoints
so W of zero well we know that that's
the balance you're going to be zero to
zero but even gave that to us in the
problem is the initial the initial state
is we have 30 cubic feet of water in the
pipe already and now what is w of 8 well
this is going to be 30 plus the definite
integral from 0 to 8 of R of X minus D
of X minus D of X DX and lucky for us
we're allowed to use a calculator so
let's use a calculator to evaluate this
and so let me get my calculator out and
actually let me go see the definitions
of R of X and D of X right over here so
I can type them in and what I'm going to
do and there's a bunch of ways the more
advanced you get with a cath later that
might save you some time from the AP
test I'm going to actually define a
function that is R of X minus D of X so
everywhere I see T I'm going to
substitute it I'm going to use an X
instead and then I could use that later
on to to integrated or to solve it in
some way so let's do that so y1 is going
to be 20 times sine of X the squared
divided by 35 close parentheses minus
open parentheses you have negative 0.04
times T to the third power or side so
I'll write times X X to the third power
plus 0.4 times x squared plus 0.96 x
times X and then I can close these
parentheses so does that make sense
20 times sine of x squared divided by 35
- negative 0.04 X to the third plus 0.4
x squared plus 0.96 times X all right
there you go I have defined y1 and now I
can use that to evaluate different
things so let me now go let me now go
back here and so let me evaluate what
this is going to be this is going to be
30 plus the definite integral I'll go to
the math functions you scroll down a
little bit you have this is the function
for definite integral function integral
and the function is y1 and I can go to
VARs go to my Y VARs it's going to be a
function variable so y1 is what I select
I could have typed it in but this will
hopefully save time and I can reuse y1
and my variable of integration is X and
I'm going from 0 to 8 from my lower
bound is 0 my upper bound is 8 and let's
see did I type everything in all right
and then let it munch a little bit and
there you have it it's approximately
48.54
for cubic feet of water at t equals 8 so
let me write that 48.54 4 so this is
approximately approximately 48.54
for cubic feet and now let's see if
there's any point in between where w
hits a local maximum point or a local
minimum point I should say I think I
said a local maximum earlier on I should
say a local minimum point and so if it's
at a local minimum or maximum point
really the derivative of W is going to
be 0 so let's see at what T do we get a
0 a 0 derivative so W prime of T well
the derivative of a constant with
respect to T is 0 and the derivative of
this with respect to T and this comes
straight out the fundamental theorem of
of calculus this is going to be this is
going to be R of T minus D of T where
once again this is a function we have T
as the upper bound and so we have
whatever here that we were integrating
but it's now going to be a function of T
and so in order for this to be equal to
0 we need to figure out when does R of T
minus
d of t equals zero and lucky for us
we've already typed in R of T minus D of
T we've defined that as Y sub one on our
calculator so let's go back here and now
I can use the solver so go to math and
then let's see if I scroll up I see all
right this is the I get to the solver I
could have scroll down as well it's
right below definite integral so I go to
the solver and I say the equation 0
equals and now I could just go to y1 so
go to my Y variables function I select
y1 so my equation is equal to y1 and I
press ENTER and now I put a I could put
an initial guess or what what x value is
going to solve that equation it's really
a T value but I'm using X as a variable
here and now I do alpha and I click
solve here so it'll glue you see right
above the enter and it gets to it gets
to well 0 is one of them let's see if I
can get if I can get another one so
let's see if I can get if I start at 2
alpha solve what a munch on that a
little bit okay so this isn't that this
is actually within the interval so three
approximately three point two seven
three point two seven two so T is
approximately three point two seven two
that's where we have a local minimum
point but now we have to evaluate W
there so we have to evaluate W at three
point two seven two to figure out if is
it truly lower than either than W 0 W of
eight is even higher than W of zero so
how do we do that well luckily we can go
back so second quit and that should be
stored under the variable X yep it's
right there
so then we can say well let's calculate
we want to calculate the function
evaluated when T is three point two
seven two so our function is thirty
thirty plus the definite integral go to
the math so definite integral
and once again we have y1 so let me go
to my Y variables function y1 we already
defined that is our R of X minus D of X
our variable of integration is X our
lower bound is 0 0 and our upper bound
is three point seven three point two
seven to which we stored in the variable
X so we can actually it's a little
confusing this is saying what's our
variable of integration this is the
actual variable this is the actual value
for our upper bound and so let's munch
on it a little bit and we get 27 point
nine six five so this is this is
approximately equal to 27 point nine six
five so now we're ready to answer what
at what time T is the amount of water in
the pipe at a minimum we can see that at
time at time three point two seven two
we have less water in the pipe than
either right when we started or right at
the end of our interval at T equals
eight so at what time T we say T is
equal to three point two seven two
we could write W of three point two
seven two is less than W of zero which
is less than W of eight so this indeed
just find knowing that the derivative
there is zero it could be a minimum or
maximum but the fact that it's lower
than both of the endpoints this is this
tells us that hey this is a this is a
minimum minimum minimum point right over
there or we could say that T equals
three point two seven two is where we
hit our minimum minimum value